Yoon Seok-yeol of the main opposition People Power Party...
...will be leading South Korea for the next five years.
Yoon was elected the country's new president early Thursday,...
...capping off one of the closest presidential races in history.
According to the National Election Commission,...
...the president-elect had 48.6% of the vote...
...against his rival Lee Jae-myung of the ruling Democratic Party's 47.8%
Yoon's gap with Lee was less than one percentage point,...
...marking the narrowest gap in all president elections held here.
Meanwhile, the number three candidate Sim Sang-jung had about 2.4% of the vote.
Although he has no governing experience,...
...Yoon made his name as a former prosecutor general...
...who pursued high-profile corruption cases.
By riding a wave of public anger at the Moon Jae-in administration,...
...Yoon appealed to many voters who wanted a change of government.
The surprise last-minute merger with Ahn Cheol-soo from the minor People's Party...
...created momentum for Yoon's victory.
The two will now work on merging the two parties.
Yoon's election pledges included improving the economy,...
...tightening the alliance with the U.S. and taking a harder line with North Korea.
He also promised a real estate supply plan,...
...which includes providing 300,000 houses to young people at cost...
...and establishing a specialized institution to reform regulations to create jobs.
But from Ukraine crisis to stalled nuclear talks with the North,...
...Yoon also has a lot of global issues to deal with once he takes the office.